is there anything that you don't do or
you can't they say we gotta you know you
do what you do
when you're sam jackson you get a bunch
of stars to come out to support and
spill secrets we live right across the
street from each
other he won't take directions she you
know i was gonna say he sings he used to
sing a song to me every morning
undirectable
that's what i am
she started you know on broadway can
take any role
and make you fall in love with him make
you hate him make you cry
sam's newest project will definitely
make you think the last days of ptolemy
gray out friday on apple tv plus is
about a man with dementia who has the
chance to get his memories back but with
a price it seemed like i can't remember
nothing no more now i know you learn and
you take a little something away from
every role that you do
you don't
i'm saying
i can't stand him
mr gray will remember everything that he
has ever known
i already knew the past is a vibrant
place and there's some bad things that
happened to you in the past but you
learn from everything there might be
some people in my past that i wouldn't
want to meet yeah but otherwise you know
pretty much everything i did
everything i did made me who i am so why
would i not want to do it again
the rate the decline is accelerating i
mean in my mind gonna be worse than it
was the folks
if you thought your days were ending you
had some days left what would you do
what would those days look like i
probably you know run around
catch up with zoe her friends i like you
know being around young people they
energize me do something good for
somebody who's uh not doing so well and
uh you know have a good meal with some
really good friends and the favorite
what's the what's the best meal
i'd have turned up green fried corn
and probably some fried chicken thought
sonia yeah baby
can you bring out some old fried thighs
we still hungry
debbie allen directed an episode and
gave me scoop about another little show
she works on we're going into the 19th
year of grey's anatomy i thought we were
finished i thought we would you did i
did
20 is a really round number sound like
my crew they come come on debbie we can
do 20. so i just say we need 20.
debbie's confirming
sam and his wife were joined by close
friends magic and cookie johnson at the
premiere magic told us he can't wait to
see sam's new show unlike another series
that just premiered the los angeles
lakers select magic johnson
have you heard of the series winning
time i'm sure you've heard of it what do
you think are you going to watch i won't
watch it because it's hard to duplicate
you can't duplicate showtime
first on the court
i mean we just did our thing it was up
and down and then off the court because
unless you
were a laker or you're a bus member
because you can't duplicate dr jerry
buss and the laker girls you can't
duplicate it so i'm not going to watch
uh now if the lakers or myself or some
lakers had something to do with it then
i would but you just can't you can't
copy that you can't it's just too much
[Music]
you